ううっうぅううだ
[音楽]
皆さんはじめまして伊藤晴紀と申します
会場にいる皆さんは様々な地域からお越しになっていると思いますので
早速ですが一つ私からお願いがあります
私の話を聞く中で自分の生まれた故郷
思い浮かべながら聞いてもらえればいいなと思っています
あなたの生まれた故郷はどんなところですか
自分の生まれた故郷は好きですか
私は秋田県能代市二ツ井町という人口1万人程度の小さな田舎町に生まれました
カタカタカタ
何の音でしょうか
私の実家ではミシンの音がなっています
両親は服を作る際方形しているのです
そんな自営業の家庭で育ち
好奇心旺盛だった私は幼い頃から様々なものに興味を持っていました
どのぐらい好奇心旺盛だったかというと
こちらをご覧ください
私はどこにいるでしょうか
ありがとうございます
そうです障子の格子をよじ登っています
両親はこんな危ないことをする私を決して
厳しくしかありませんでした
むしろいつも畑高く見守っていました
この見守るというのは肺底の心遣いを表すのではないでしょうか
空間的にを離れていても
心と心がつながる安心感
安心感があったからこそ私はどんなことにもチャレンジする気持ちが育まれたんだと
思います
今振り返ると両親がずっとそばにいる
恵まれた幼少期を過ごしていたのです
そこから月日が流れ私が高校生の時の2006年
平成の大合併
というものがありました
合併とは複数の自治体が一つの自治体にまとまることです
この当時私の故郷である二ツ井町は隣の能代市とかっぺいしました
数であればこの事実を鵜呑みにするのですが
当時の私はあれ
と思ったのです
少し大げさかもしれませんが
自分の故郷がなくなってしまうのではないか
思ったのです
今冷静になってみるとそんなことないってわかるんですけどね
でもこの自分の故郷がなくなるかもしれないという感覚は間違いではありませんでした
2014年
日本創成会議の中で消滅可能性都市
というキーワードがたされました
これは2040年までに少子化や人口流出に歯止めがかからず
存続できなくなる恐れのある自治体を指します
特に衝撃的だったのが私の故郷がある
秋田県が
大潟村を除くすべての実際に該当するというものでした
生まれて初めて自分の故郷を意識した瞬間でした
想像してみてください
自分の故郷がなくなる
もしそうなったら悲しくないですか
私は当時とても寂しい気持ちになったこと
今でも鮮明に覚えています
この危機的状況をどうにかすることはできないか
私は悩みました
自分の故郷を何とかしたい
そして大学生の私は一つの決断をします
自分の故郷を全く知らないまずはもっとふるさとを知ろう
そう思い団体を立ち上げたのです
アークグループ
秋田リージョンコントリビューションこの3つの頭文字から名付けました
地域活性化を目的とした団体です
私の故郷を何とかしたいという思いに共感した仲間で立ち上げました
設立当初から秋田県内の
さまざまな地域に行ける
いろんな人たちと一緒にプロジェクトができるなどの理由から
人と人との和がどんどん広がり設立1年後には100名を超える団体と成長
地域の祭りやボランティア活動に参加したり
資源マップを作ったり
農作業体験だと思いました
活動中はいつもたくさんの笑顔が負0
地域の方々も学生も楽しみながら活動していました
活動するたびに学生も増え
連携する地域もどんどん広がっていきました
地域の方々と学生のみんなの思いが紡がれてきた団体となっていたのです
でもこの華やかな活動を裏で実は私は悩んでいました
それは地域活性化とは何か
ということです
学生は普段のできない体験ができる
地域の方は普段だと話すことのない世代と交流し元気をもらえる
win-win な関係性が築けている
でもふと思ったんです
こんなことをして本当に地域活性化はなっているのだろうか
地域活性化とは目に見えないものだからこそ自分が行っている活動に
自信をなくしてしまったのです
そんなとき手を差し伸べてくれたのがエンターの浜の先生でした
濱田先生はアークグループ施術前から私たちを世話してくださった方です
先生に尋ねました
学生の役割は何ですか
先生は答えます
いとく
学生の役割は地域の自立を促すこと
背中を押すことだよ
地域の方々の背中を吸う
一人一人の腎臓を生かすこと
つまりは人を起こしだ
突然くらい見に一つ子の光が
差し込んだかのようにいままでやってきた活動が鮮明によみがえってきました
確かに学生の入っている地域では主体的な活動が展開されています
地域の方々がみれば当たり前だった日常の風景
学生の新たな支援が加わり地域の資源とかある
人と人とが互いの良さを認め合っている
まさに win-win な関係性が築けている
あの時先生に相談しなければ私はこの正解の皆世界からいなくなっていたのかもしれ
ません
このような活動をして8年が経ちました
さまざまな地域と関わらせていただき私は今地域おこし協力隊として活動しています
地域おこし協力隊党は総務省が設置したもので任期は3年です
移住者を増やすのが葉もなミッションですが学生時代に濱田先生から教えていただいた
人を起こし
考え方に基づき活動しています
魅力あふれる地域には魅力的な人がたくさんいます
主体的な地域には加害口同士がたくさんいます
地域は一人一人の人間が作ります
輝く人たちが増えれば
地域も活性化すると私は考えています
これが
地域おこしは人を起こしと言われる所以です
ではきっと起こしをするためにどうしたらいいでしょうか
それはその人のやりたいことや夢を実現させること
私が協力隊としか彼はたチゲを紹介します
秋田県男鹿市はなまはげで有名です
なまはげ行事とは
2018年
11月にユネスコの無形民俗文化財に登録されましたが私の活動するます彼はという
約100世帯ほどの集落ではこのなまはげ行事が12年間途絶えていました
ます川のように
少子高齢化が進み
なまはげを担う若手がいなくなった地域では
途絶えたところが少なくありません
この現状にショック受け会長さんのなまはげがまた見たい
という夢をかなえるため私は知人たちの力を借りて
この行事の復活を決意します
10月ごろから会長さんと話しやすすめ
徐々に地域の人を巻き込んできました
そして2018年12月31日の大晦日
無事復活
12年越しの夢を叶えたことで地域の方々にたくさんの笑顔があふれました
そしてこの時がついたのです
私は
地域の方々の背中を教え
今もの役名になっていたんです
その結果回調査をはじめとした地域の方々みんなの思いを積むことができたのです
地域おこしとは目に見えなく理論並べるだけではいけません
そこに住む人々の心があり
人間同士の心と心のコミュニケーションがなければ成立しません
まるで一人一に思いを見えないとで紡いでいくように
そして心が共鳴したときに初めて同じ目標に向かいいい
たくさんの想いが紡がれて夢がかなうんだと思います
でもまず人の夢を叶えたいのであれば自分の夢を実現させなければなりません
私の夢の一つは祖父のように地域貢献で表彰されることでした
それが学生時代の活動で叶えました
実はもう一つあります
それはこのてレックスの場合ていること
facebook で記事をシェアしていたのが2015年の秋
まさかこの4年で実現するとは
これもプレゼンテーに所プレゼンターに紹介してくださった方が紡いでくれた変だと
思っています
この場でまた一つの夢を叶えることができました
次はまた誰かの夢を一緒に叶えられればいいなと思っています
今回のプレゼンで
自分の故郷への見方が少しでも変わり
私のように故郷を何とかしたいという人が笑われるのではなく一緒に活動できたらいい
なと思っています
最後に皆さんにお尋ねします
あなたは夢をあきらめていませんか
それは一人でできることですか
1人でできないのであればみんなでその思いを詰めていきましょう
ご静聴ありがとうございました
[拍手]